the former leader is accused of having
helped the smuggling of 500 tons of
cocaine mainly from colombia and
venezuela through honduras to the united
states
the extradition judge has decided to
grant this extradition which has been
requested by the court of the supreme
district of new york
u.s prosecutors allege the politician
received millions of dollars from
traffickers including mexican drug
cartel boss joaquin el chapo guzman
the 53-year-old denies the accusations
saying they are a revenge plot by rival
drug gangs
his supporters rallied outside the
supreme court in the capital tagucicalpa
he was the only president who extradited
many drug traffickers and the united
states is allowing itself to be led by
all the lies of the drug traffickers he
extradited those are the allegations
they have and the evidence they have
from the drug traffickers
hernandez was arrested last month after
being holed up in his home for hours by
police
if convicted he faces a mandatory
minimum sentence of 40 years
his brother and former congressman was
sentenced to life in prison last year
for similar offenses
prior to his eight-year presidency
hernandez was pro-american and supported
washington's so-called war on drugs
his wife expressed her despair
i sincerely regret that this is being
done to someone who's been an ally i
wonder from now on who else will want to
work to combat drug trafficking in
neighboring countries or in honduras
hernandez is expected to appeal the
extradition ruling and has three days to
announce his decision
chilean wolf al jazeera